may in cincinnati ohio
what's up may how we doing
hey doctor john how are you so good so
good how is cincinnati
ah chilly that's
if you live above oklahoma for the next
four months the
the the normal response is cold chilly
dark so anyway that's awesome okay so
how can i help today may
okay so um i was calling a couple years
ago
my husband's
parents died in a car accident hey take
a breath take a breath
and um he has chosen to cope with
alcohol
oh man i'm so sorry
[Music]
i'm trying to collect myself sorry no
you're good so while you're doing that
i'll
restate it so a couple of years ago your
husband's parents
tragically died was it a car wreck
yes okay so they died suddenly and out
of the blue in a car wreck
and your husband has chosen to cope with
that
with alcohol that's been his his
numbing um methodology of choice over
the last few years right
yes and it has started to spiral out of
control
remember coming up on three years and
i'm just starting to feel really
resentful of him
tell me he's just he just really checks
out
and i don't know how to to deal with all
these feelings i have
so talk to me about him you said i feel
resentful i want you to verbalize
for me what is that what is that what
does resentful mean
um he works and he drinks and that is
about the extent of his day
yeah um he comes home he just he he
disconnects from me he just connects
with the kids
he doesn't really engage with us he
doesn't help me around the house
i have begged pleaded cried
for him to get help to to help me
and he's just he just doesn't hear me he
would rather just
drink and spend time on his phone and
just
shut down
so i'm going to ask a couple of probing
questions okay and you can you don't
even have to go into them you can just
yes or no i'm okay i'm trying to get a
full picture
of your husband here has he been
faithful all three years
um about a year ago i found him
found out he was talking to other women
online okay
has he ever been with any of them he
says no
okay and none of them were local so i i
doubt it okay
um is he going to work is he staying
is he he's drinking uh his drinking
hasn't taken over the point that he's
not going to work anymore right
no he goes he's probably hungover or
maybe still drunk but he goes
okay tell me about his parenting is he
engaged with your kids or is he just
completely checked out
it's completely checked out okay how old
are your kids
uh well they're his kids my kids are
grown
okay um they're 14 and 15. okay
and how long have you all been married
um
about 13 years 13 years
tell me about the man he was before this
before the accident
um honestly it's really
hard to there's like
it's just been so much that it's really
hard to remember all the good things
because i'm
so deep in resentment at this point
he was more engaged um with the kids and
as the family
um he drank but it was casually
and then he never grieved this never
never
dug into his feelings about his
appearance and and worked through this
he just checked out huh
yeah okay so
i'm gonna give you some hard truth okay
and i'm gonna be as
honest with you as i can at the same
time as compassion as i can
because they're only words that can
describe the situation and this just
sucks
and i hate this for you and this your
second marriage is that right
no it's my first your first marriage
okay but you have other grown kids
yeah my kids are older yeah okay
um yeah this sucks so here's the thing
resentment is the nails in the coffin of
a relationship
it is very very hard to come back from
resentment
and if somebody's sitting in front of me
and they are
having to choose between anger and rage
and resentment i'll take anger and rage
seven days out of the week
i mean seven days yeah seven days a week
because resentment is so hard to come
back from it's just
poison and it's also not unfounded
right the guy you married a decade in
experienced a life-altering tragedy and
he disappeared on you
right i want you to as much as you can
get out of his head and get out of his
heart
because that's gonna kill you literally
okay
why he's doing what he's doing is feels
personal and it feels
like it's an attack on you and if he's a
true
debilitated alcoholic it probably has
little to nothing to do with you
okay he's got a whole bunch of demons
he's trying to keep at bay
does that make it right no is it
ridiculous yes
is it killing everybody in your house
yes but
you getting in his head and trying to
figure out why he's doing this
i wish he was doing this if he would ju
that's only
beating you up it's not solving any of
your problems
and so you've got to make a plan there
is no relational healing while
somebody's
an alcoholic there just isn't
there is no way people get well until
people get sober
because you're not dealing with the
person you're dealing with the shadow of
a person
and this goes to people who work 120
hours a week and someone wants to fix
their marriage
then they got to stop because they're
addicted to busyness
and folks who are addicted to fill in
the blank
pornography drugs alcohol whatever the
addiction is whatever the numbing
behavior is they have to
stop that for a period of time before
any relational healing can happen
and so what i'm telling you is you are
now in a place
three years later this isn't a phase
this has become a way of life
your kids deserve better than this you
deserve better than this
and your husband deserves better than
this right
he is admits despair and that sucks
but until he decides through his own
heart that he wants to get well
then um your relationship is going to be
what your relationship is
and so what you have to do is you got to
start making decisions for yourself
and that's going to look like getting
some people that you trust in your life
that will sit down with you
walk alongside you whether that's an
intervention with your husband whether
that
is you saying i'm going to move out for
30 days until you decide to get yourself
well
whether that is you deciding this is
just going to be what this is for the
next five or six years until the kids
graduate whatever that happens to be
but resentment is it's just like the old
aaa saying resentment is poisoning
yourself and hoping he's going to die
you're the one that's bearing the brunt
of that resentment and those kids not
him
and so when you think about um
if if you were to move out tomorrow or
you were to ask him to move out tomorrow
does that give you relief and peace in
your heart or does that make you real
anxious
and angry and frustrated anxious
why why does it make you feel anxious
because it feels like it's just removing
him from
the situation where he would probably
just be able to drink in peace and i'd
still have
all the responsibilities because i don't
know that he would be capable of taking
care of the kid
and do you hear that language that
you're talking about you've got to got
to
make peace with that you are the only
one taking care of those kids and it's
going to be that way for the foreseeable
future
and the longer you lean into i have to
take care of these kids
and it's because of him you're literally
poisoning yourself
okay you're going to have to change the
way you talk to yourself that voice
inside your own head
because the chemical response of your
body is poisoning you
you just are living off cortisol and
adrenaline for the last two or three
years
my guess is you probably haven't had a
chance to grieve either because you've
been trying to
keep a duct-taped house together
right have you met with somebody have
you ever sat down with a counselor and
just says
here's my last couple of years
i started to yeah um
probably about a year ago okay and she
really just like honed in on his
drinking
mm-hmm and like how i needed to get him
help and i didn't
that's helpful listen that's a crappy
therapist dude because you can't help
somebody like that all you can help is
you
right and so i want to
tell you that your therapist didn't do a
good job and
there's somebody out there in your local
community that's going to be great
okay and so i want to encourage you to
go again because you're at the plan
making stage now
you are at the what is going to be next
for me because now i'm living with
a alcoholic who was a functional
alcoholic and now he's disappearing
because the next step
is he's going to skip a day at work and
then he's gonna not
go back the next day and then he's gonna
stop being employed
this is just a trajectory now okay
okay and the older your kids get they're
absorbing
every second of that tension every
second of that resentment and you're
going to have to do the best you can to
double down on how much you love them
make sure you are touching their face
every day i want you to hold their face
every day until the moment you love them
tell them how grateful you are that you
get to be their mom
i want you to plan and then you're
exhausted i know
but i want you to plan dates with them
i want you to just go pick up donuts
every once in a while and i think eating
donuts is terrible but
there's just some joy right nothing a
little carbs and sugar can't take the
edge off of
i want you to find joy and
giving them laughter and i want you to
find joy in giving them connection
because that connection and laughter is
going to heal you too
but until you let him off and he's out
you got to just
begin setting up each morning without
him in the picture because he's gone
okay i have a hundred percent
faith in redemption i've just known too
many former alcoholics who
completely turned around and sometimes
it takes an intervention sometimes it
takes rock bottom sometimes it takes
filling
any number of blanks but i do know this
about addiction the only person that can
help somebody
get well with alcohol is them they have
to make that decision and then they got
to seek out a community
that's going to walk alongside them for
the rest of their lives
and that's going to involve dealing with
your parents his parents death that's
going to involve dealing with the
pain of this marriage that's gonna i
mean that's gonna
be a lot of adventures he's gonna have
to walk through
and if you're by his side oh that'd be
so beautiful it'd be great
but also you need to live in the reality
that
you're living with an addict and your
relationship will not get well until he
chooses to to get himself well
and until you choose to get yourself
well and you are living on
bitterness rage right now
resentment is that fair i think some of
yeah that's right i think some of it is
like we've had conversations where i've
confronted him on the drinking maybe
confronted the bad word but
like you talked with him about it and he
like acknowledges it
that it's a problem and it's causing
issues in her marriage and then
what he does now is he hides it from me
right and
and continuing to challenge him on the
drinking is futile
i want you just to stop doing that it's
not helpful okay
it's not going to change if he knew how
to be connected with you
if he knew how to fully be loved by you
if he knew how to grieve the loss of his
parents
and to grieve the loss of his innocence
and how to be a father who's
totally present with his teenage kids he
wouldn't need
alcohol and if he was able to process
childhood traumas that existed he would
need to
numb that out and so he can't and so
um at this point beating him up about it
isn't helping
that drives it underground like you just
said
and so what he needs is you to love him
but you also you need to begin to love
you
and you need to begin to honor yourself
and
those kids and that starts with you
healing from the inside out
and you cannot do that by yourself and
you can't do it with an addict so you're
going to have to go get a counselor
you're going to have to get a group of
women in your community that you can
trust
you can sit with not for griping and
whining sessions
but for sessions where they can just
hear your feelings hear your pain
sit with you and then walk with you as
you begin to
heal from that healing may look like
therapy it may look like you being
really intentional about
a workout program and a nutrition
program
it may look like you being really
intentional about being a hyper
connected parent doubling down on those
kids and loving them
it may look like you journaling and
doing gratitude work every single day so
you begin to shift your default setting
from one of resentment and
that piece of crap who's just sitting on
the couch dragging this boat under water
you cut that rope you cut the rope he's
not gonna anchor you down anymore and
then y'all gonna rise above it so
but that starts with you honoring
yourself and
my my opinion is you need to get a
counselor you find a new counselor it's
not going to spend all your money and
your time talking about somebody else
who's going to talk about you
and what you can do to get well and then
you run from there so
may thank you so much for the call
that's a hard one man because there's
not an easy solution
and you're on a long long journey that's
why i just started the whole call with
saying this sucks
because you're in it now um but we'll be
thinking about you
if you decide to make some major
transitions if you decide to
have an intervention with his friends
and his family if you decide to
um go see somebody call me back let me
know how your
your walk and your journey is going and
i'll be here to help